[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a film called iron sky the
coming race spoilers ahead watch out
hence take care
thirty years ago in 2017 humankind found
that a group of high-ranking nazis is
inhabiting the dark side of the moon
they were secretly sent to the moon base
during world war ii and were forgotten
after living in the dark for over a
decade the lunar nazis were told about
their defeat in world war ii and the
death of their great leader they wanted
to take revenge on everyone who
slandered their propaganda which
ultimately gave rise to a nuclear war
between lunar nazis and the earth humans
the war went on for only a year but it
ended with the earth turning into a
radioactive mess the climate turned so
extreme that even the dry lands were
covered in snow the ones who didn't die
in the war were killed due to radiation
while the others died because of the
climate in such conditions the remaining
thousand human survivors found a way to
sustain life in the same moon base where
the nazis had been living before the war
they boarded the last spaceship and made
their way to the dark side of the moon
the plan worked and they found a new
home despite the limited resources the
surviving humans have lived on the dark
side of the moon for 30 years they grow
food using a mineral found on the moon's
surface but they are running out of it
at a frightening rate moreover frequent
and increasingly aggressive moonquakes
put the lives of the residents in great
danger the leader of the moon people is
a woman named renat who works her best
to maintain resources for her people but
with her growing age the responsibility
falls onto her young daughter obi like
in any dystopian situation there is a
single community that is still living a
better life than the others they are a
small group of former moon nazis who are
currently tech obsessed maniacs they
worship steve jobs and think that anyone
who changes their mobile settings from
the default must suffer a horrible death
their leader is a man named donald who
terminates the people who disobey their
rules through a mobile app that blows
them into pieces obie and renaud are
extremely against donald and his group
but they reluctantly have to coexist
with them one day renat and her
councilmen notice a strange spacecraft
approaching their base from the surface
of the earth they are shocked to
discover that someone was alive on earth
for all these years and are even more
surprised that earth humans managed to
build a working spaceship renat wants to
terminate the entire ship and kill
whoever is inside because the last time
lunar and earth humans met the result
was not good however obi goes against
the entire council and initiates a
system malfunction so her mother won't
attack the alien spaceship she also
assists them in landing and meets the
few surviving earth humans it turns out
that they lived in an underground bunker
in russia after the war but the
radiation spread over the years and they
ran out of food supplies which is why
they have come to ask the moon people
for help obi wants to know how the earth
humans found out about the moon base but
no one has the answer the leader of the
earth group is sasha and he is also the
engineer who built the ship he is
delighted that they finally have a new
home until renat reveals the moon
doesn't have enough resources to sustain
them they need a magnificent source of
energy if they want to continue living
here which is nearly impossible to find
in such a limited time for now the new
earthlings are kept in storage rooms and
given food and water obi gets to fixing
a space station that was cannibalized
for its parts years ago people looked at
momentary benefits back then but if the
station was still working they would
have a place to stay when the moonquakes
made the base uninhabitable obi believes
that she can fix the space station with
the right equipment but she will never
get enough lunar minerals to energize
the launch while working on the ship's
engine she notices a man sneaking into
the abandoned nazi offices she follows
him but the man takes her by surprise
and knocks her out when obi wakes up she
finds herself in the old fuhrer's office
the man is someone who came with the
earthlings on the ship earlier upon
being asked what he wants he reveals
that he is none other than the lunar
furor and the commander of the nazi army
from world war three ob is shocked
mostly because he hasn't aged a day
since the war say what you will about
the nazis they have great skin care
routines obie wants to tell her mother
about his presence and execute him but
the fuhrer bribes her with something she
cannot refuse he claims to have a
magical substance that will save her
dying mother to prove himself fuhrer
cuts off one of his fingers which
surprisingly regenerates in an instant
obi decides to give him a chance and
brings the chocolate-like magical thing
to her mother after eating it ranat's
year-long disease is cured she also ages
backwards and is seemingly young donald
watches them from hiding shocked by the
discovery obi then returns to fuhrer and
asks him to explain what is going on the
man starts by disclosing that he is an
alien reptilian species called namek i
mean vrils long ago when dinosaurs were
still alive obie his brother hitler who
you might have heard of and many more of
their kind landed on earth they took
over it and raised dinosaurs as
livestock until the asteroids hit and
killed the animals the vrils didn't lose
hope and continued to live as the only
rational inhabitants of the earth then
one day the lunar furor decided to
conduct a small experiment on his pet
monkeys adam and eve the vril survive on
a special nectar called vrylia which is
the source of their long life and
regenerative powers adam and eve were
given this nectar and their evolution
was accelerated which resulted in the
existence of modern day humans following
their appearance the vrils disguised
themselves as humans and continued
living among them several millenniums
later the war occurred and humans were
wiped off the face of the earth vrils
learned their lesson and vowed to never
make the mistake of reviving humans
again the fuhrer's brother hitler is the
leader of the vrils and he hates humans
fuhrer on the other hand wants to aid
them but more than that he hates his
brother and wants to make his life a
living hell hence he is ready to help
obie and humankind against the vrils obi
still doesn't understand the entire
story and inquires where the vrils live
it is then revealed that they have
inhabited the inside of the earth which
is apparently hollow the place has an
alternative for the sun which is powered
by a jar of vrylia if obi can bring the
jar to the moon they can power the space
station and continue living in the
earth's orbit far from moonquakes and
their danger the energy produced will
also help them grow unlimited crops
making it the only way humanity can
survive obi doesn't waste time before
asking sasha for help because he can
pilot his spaceship back to the earth
they are joined by a national guardsman
named malcolm and ultimately by donald
and his group who insist on coming obi
has a map provided by the fuhrer and his
cut-off finger which he thinks will help
her at some point in the following scene
sasha's ship enters the earth's
atmosphere they choose a random landing
site and somehow land perfectly on the
opening of the earth's core the ship
crashes without any severe damage and
the group finally sees the beautiful
inner earth if they defeat the vrils the
humans might get their planet back but
they don't seem to be smart enough to
even think of that possibility for now
obi just wants to steal the virulia
powering the alternate sun to navigate
around the place they use sasha's nokia
3000 after being distracted by the snake
game for a while they continue the
mission and make their way to a more
crowded area then we are introduced to
the council of the vrils which consists
of hitler mark zuckerberg osama bin
laden and many other known figures trump
and bezos must have called in sick today
they believe that they have become a
better community after the humans were
wiped out hitler is still as strict as
ever and makes his councilman
cannibalize the president when she tries
to go against his propaganda upon
reaching the vril market donald and his
followers are shocked because their
prophet steve jobs is taking a stroll
obi warns them to stay away from him but
they believe steve would never hurt his
followers they make a stupid decision
and soon regret it when the vril guards
surround them obi sasha and malcolm run
away while being followed by the rest of
the guards malcolm takes the
responsibility to distract them while
the other two escape because they need
vrylia at any cost
after saving their lives the duo dresses
up as vril guards and goes to the
entrance of the temple where the virulia
is kept the temple guards do not suspect
them unaware of the presence of humans
on earth it turns out that the finger
fuhrer gave obi can be used to open the
gates to the temple it comes in handy
and the two finally get a full view of
the magnificent vrilia powering the
alternate sun in the meantime donald and
his group alongside malcolm are taken to
hitler by now their unwavering trust in
their leader has wavered away and they
are willing to do anything to save their
lives donald proposes hitler take his
people in as refugees in turn for their
lifelong loyalty malcolm reminds him of
czechoslovakia to make a point that
hitler is not so good with promises in
turn donald and his entire group are
attacked and eaten alive by hitler's
councilman malcolm however is left alive
for no reason other than that he is one
of the good guys back in the temple obie
climbs up to get to the virulia sasha
predicts the weight of the nectar to be
more than a thousand kilos obi still
takes her chances and picks it up to
reveal that he meant a thousand ounces
not kilograms with nature's nectar in
their possession the two now have to
rescue malcolm and return to their home
on the moon by now donald and his people
have turned into mashed meat for the
vrils hitler and steve are conspiring
against the inhabitants of the moon when
malcolm breaks the chains with pure
human strength and attacks them this
gives rise to a chase between the
entirety of vril and three humans who
have stolen their only source of
sustainable life the fight is clearly on
the vril side but the winners are
obviously going to be the protagonists
after a few minutes of high-speed
chariot chase malcolm and sasha defeat
bin laden hitler steve and all the other
vrils they finally reach the spaceship
and fly back home in victory what they
do not notice is a mountain-like thing
emerging from the earth's surface and
following them into space upon finally
reaching the moon renaut welcomes her
daughter and praises all three of them
for their bravery just when they think
this is the happy ending the lunar furor
shows his true face even though he is
the creator of human life he doesn't
want to let them live and only use them
to get the virula he shoots malcolm in
the leg and threatens to kill renat as
well if they do not follow his orders
suddenly a loud bang is heard and hitler
arrives look and bus in his hell on the
mountain-like structure joining the
earth to the moon the brothers face each
other after several years ready to fight
one final battle hitler has the upper
hand given the dinosaur he's riding but
the fuhrer doesn't back down either the
moon is again hit with another
aggressive moonquake which is bound to
make it uninhabitable when the people
are on the verge of death renaut takes a
gulp of the virulia and fights hitler
she is stronger than ever with her new
powers and manages to yank hitler off
his ride a heavy metal box falls on him
finally killing the villain of the
millennium meanwhile obi makes her
people board the space station and sasha
powers it using the remainder of the
nectar hobie wants to help her mother
into the ship but sees her being killed
under the wreckage still she maintains
her cool and pilots the space station to
earth's orbit but the problems haven't
ended yet the fuhrer who is still alive
hacks the station's control panel from
the moon he is seconds away from blowing
it up when obi gets an idea she uses the
nokia cell phone to trigger the
termination app on fuhrer's cell
although donald was an idiot his program
kills the fuhrer and saves humanity in
the last scene we see obi and sasha
enjoying their life as the power couple
of the space station people live a happy
life and are looking to settle down on
mars in a few years subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching